[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello,
and welcome to
YouTube Developers Live.
I have an exciting show
for you today.
In London, we have
Ross McIlroy.
How are we doing, Ross?
ROSS MCILROY: Doing good.
Thanks.
How are you?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Doing great.
And my name is Jarek
Wilkiewicz.
I work on YouTube Developer
Relations.
Today, we'll talk about the
YouTube Android Player API.
If you have watched our Google
I/O presentation, you might
actually recognize Ross, who was
one of the presenters at
that session.
I understand you've been quite
busy since Google I/O, Ross.
That was earlier this year.
Can you tell us what
you've been up to?
ROSS MCILROY: Sure.
So we've been working with
some trusted testers on
refining the API, making sure
it works well, adding some
missing features, and making
sure that all of the bits are
in place to make sure we can
enable you to play all the
YouTube content embedded
within your app.
So just final polishing
and ready for launch.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So I know that you have built
a set of demos to help
application developers
use the API.
Should we look at a couple of
the examples that are included
as a part of the release?
ROSS MCILROY: Sure.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Let's start with
the video wall.
I'll launch it right now.
ROSS MCILROY: Sure.
So the video is an example of
what you might be able to do
with the app by putting all the
components of the API together.
So it's a simple demo of
thumbnails flipping.
And then one of the thumbnails
will flip in
and turn into a video.
So that shows you how you can
embed the videos within your
UI and play and pause them
programmatically.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And moving along, there is
a simple player view demo
included as well.
Can you tell us when one might
want to include this code?
ROSS MCILROY: Sure.
So the simple player view is
just the simplest possible
approach to using the
API with embedding a
video into your app.
So this is just embedding
a simple player
view into the UI.
I have nothing else apart from
text here, but you could put
whatever you want above.
And it's just showing how simple
it is to embed the
player view.
We also have the simple player
fragment, which is basically
the same demo but using YouTube
player fragment as
opposed to player view.
You might want to use
that if you need to
extend a different activity.
For the player view, you need to
extend our activity that we
provide as part of the API.
The fragment, you could extend
any activity you like and just
embed the fragment.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And custom player controls.
ROSS MCILROY: So this is just
a demo of wiring up UI
controls to the programmatic
elements of the player.
So you can play/plause with the
buttons, which are under
your control.
And underneath, we have an event
log, which is showing
the various callbacks that you
can register and listen for,
for example, playing videos,
seeing when the video's ended,
when the user has pressed
pause, et cetera.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And I understand you've made
some improvements to
full-screen handling, which is
something that is always very
tricky for developers.
Custom full-screen handling
illustrates that one.
ROSS MCILROY: It does.
Yes.
And by default, full screen is
a dialogue which appears on
top of your activity.
And so that works very well,
but it sometimes introduces
some buffering.
So custom full screen shows our
best practices on how to
deal with full screen.
And so in that case, you have to
manage the [? relay out ?]
to full screen yourself.
But by doing that, you get a
really smooth transition to
full screen with no buffering.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Indeed.
And there is a demo that shows
you how you can actually
include full screen in your
application here.
Is that the overlay
action bar demo?
ROSS MCILROY: Yes.
So the overlay action bar demo
is just showing how you can
overlay an action bar on top of
the player [? palettes ?]
in full-screen mode, as
long as the action
bar has overlay set.
And so this is to enable you
to, for example, have some
custom buttons in the action bar
to enable some control for
your app and [? palettes ?]
in full screen.
Because we don't need allow
you to overlay any custom
views on top of the player
itself other
than the action bar.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Right.
And then I've seen applications
performing video
playback into a lightbox.
Which demo actually shows
that feature?
ROSS MCILROY: So that's the
standalone player demo.
And so that one's just showing
a different approach to
playing video, which is not
embedding it in your UI but
instead launching a
separate activity.
So it's much simpler to do,
but you don't get as much
flexibility or control.
So if you click the lightbox
mode, and you play the video,
you can see the video
appearing above
the underlying activity.
So that's a good option if you
want to just show a quick
preview of a video alongside
your UI.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Great.
And these examples are packaged
together as a part of
the API release, right?
ROSS MCILROY: Yeah,
that's right.
We provide them in
the library.
So you can get going.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Let's walk through the API.
So can you tell us a little more
about what is the process
of integration between this
API and one's Android
application?
ROSS MCILROY: Sure.
So once you the zip, you'll
have the sample apps and a
library directory, which
contains the JAR of the API.
And so to embed the API in your
own application, all you
need to do is take that JAR,
copy it to the LIBS directory
in your project root.
And if you have any clips-- or
[INAUDIBLE], I think, as
well-- it will automatically
add that
to your Java classpath.
And then you can just use
it straight away.
It's already in your app.
One thing you'll need to do is
register for a developer key
on the Google APIs console.
And so once you've done that,
you can initialize the API and
make use of it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then there's actually four
different ways in which video
playback can be incorporated
into your Android application.
Can you walk us through
the API?
I know we have Java docs with
all this information.
Maybe real quickly
show us what are
kind of the key classes.
ROSS MCILROY: Sure.
So the final demo we
showed there was
the standalone player.
So this is the class for
You can see the code here.
We have an example fragment.
It's just two lines of code to
create that standalone player.
Just pass in your video ID
that you want to play.
And there's various different
intents you can create with
this class to play videos
or playlists or use
the lightbox mode.
And then once you start the
intent, that will throw up the
activity, which will
play the video.
So that's a really simple
but less flexible
way of playing videos.
If you want to really embed the
YouTube videos into your
UI, we provide these
three classes.
There's the player view, the
player fragment, and the
player support fragment.
So they all effectively
act in the same way.
They provide a view, which you
can inflate in your app UI or
programmatically instantiate.
Once you have that, you call the
initialize method on that
UI element, pass your
developer key on
InitializeListener.
And then you'll get a call
back through your own
InitializeListener about when
you've succeeded in
initializing the API.
And with that callback, you'll
get one of these YouTube
player objects.
And so the YouTube player object
is basically the main
object in the whole API.
So this allows you to control
video playback in those UI
player views or player
fragments.
And so you can load videos,
queue videos, skip between
playlist elements, and seek the
video, do all the things
you would expect from
such an API.
And also register for various
callback events, playback
events, or changes in
the player state
or full-screen events.
And so the final way you can
play YouTube videos using this
API is through the YouTube
intents class.
And so this is basically just
a convenience mechanism to
enable you to create intents
which will launch the YouTube
Android application itself.
So a lot of people have been
using this in the past to play
videos by building their own
YouTube URLs and passing that
as the intent.
This just creates a standardized
way of doing that
with various options for
starting the video in full
screen or playing playlists or
opening a user's activity in
the app itself.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: YouTube
standalone player is the
simplest way to get started.
Player view and player fragment
will alone one to
build a more sophisticated
user interface.
And then YouTube intents class
basically wraps the intents
that are available from
the YouTube app.
And it just invokes the app
from one's application.
ROSS MCILROY: Yeah.
Exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And you mentioned that as a
part of the initialization
process, one can actually
encounter various error
conditions.
Can you quickly walk us through
what these errors are
and what are the best practices
around handling them?
ROSS MCILROY: You get this
on-initialize failure result,
which will provide a YouTube
initialization result
alongside the callback.
So this is an enum that
has various options
for what went wrong.
And so various things
could go wrong in
connecting to the API service.
So one of the ones which
you could encounter is
DEVELOPER_KEY_INVALID, if
you've not got a valid
developer key, or
INVALID_APPLICATION_SIGNATURE.
So we require that your
application's APK has been
signed in the same way that it
would be signed to be uploaded
onto the Google Play Store.
And then there's various other
ones, which can be
recoverable.
So this example is a
SERVICE_DISABLED,
SERVICE_MISSING, or
SERVICE_VERSION_
UPDATE_REQUIRED.
So if you get one of these
initialization results, then
the method issues a recoverable
error will return true.
And so this means that there's
something that the user can do
to make the API work.
And so what they may have done
is disabled the YouTube app.
Or they may have
uninstalled it.
Or they may have an old version
which doesn't have the
API service available.
And so if you have one of these
errors, you can call and
get error dialogue on the
YouTube initialization result.
It will create a dialogue for
you, which identifies the
problem to the user.
For example, they need to
update the YouTube app.
And it gives them a button to
press, which will take them
straight to market and enable
them to update it there.
And once they return to your
activity, we'll pass back the
request code that you've passed
into the get error
dialogue on activity result.
And you can check whether the
resolution was successful or
not, and if so, reinitialize
the player
view or player fragment.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So sounds like the two
common errors will be
developer key related.
So the API does require
developer key, unlike the
existing player APIs.
In fact, I've noticed people
that we've worked with
frequently run into
this issue with
trying to run the examples.
So you actually have to go in
and change the developer key.
And you can obtain that Version
3.0 developer key from
our developer console.
If you need to know more about
YouTube Data API v3, go to our
blog, apiblog.youtube.com, where
you will find a lot of
additional information.
This API was recently
launched.
And then the other one, which is
actually user recoverable,
is related to a version check
that the API performs.
And this is where the
application developer can
actually work in concert with
the user and help the user
update the app if that is, in
fact, necessary in order for
the API to function
on the device.
And then the API supports
Android Version 2.2 and above.
Is that correct?
ROSS MCILROY: Yeah.
2.2 and above.
Froyo all the way
to Jellybean.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So another question I had
about the API is, do you
support live stream playback?
ROSS MCILROY: So we support
live stream playback.
But due to the video format
that's used by YouTube, only
Android devices from Honeycomb
MR1 and above will support
live videos.
So that would be version
3.1 of the platform.
If the devices is version 3.1 or
above, they will be able to
play live videos.
Otherwise, they won't.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Speaking of compatibility, I
guess the fundamental question
an application developer might
ask is, is the library
compatible with my device?
Do I actually have all
the prerequisites for
the library to run?
So how can one determine
whether the library is
actually supporting
one's device?
ROSS MCILROY: Sure.
Yeah.
So we provide this YouTube
API ServiceUtil class.
And within that, there is a
isYouTubeAPIServiceAvailable call.
And when you call that, you'll
get back again one of these
YouTube initialization
results.
So that'll, again, either give
you the success result, which
means the API's there and
available, and you can use it.
Or it might give you one of
the ones which you can
initialize a dialogue
to enable the
user to recover from.
Or there may be some other
error, which you can identify
and use another mechanism
to play back the video.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then As far as the
initialization [? part, ?]
say if I'm working on an older
Android device, is there
anything that I need to
be worried about?
Can you tell us a little bit
more about-- how long does it
take to initialize
the library?
ROSS MCILROY: So the
initialization is
asynchronous.
And the reason for that is it
can sometimes take some time
to spin up the activity which
the service is provided by.
So on older devices, if the
YouTube app isn't already
running, it may take a second
or so for that to happen.
Now, once that's happening,
the UI of the player has a
spinner loading.
And it's not blocking
the UI thread.
So it's not going
to affect your
animations or your graphics.
But the player's not going
to be available
until that's happened.
So if you are worried about this
on older devices, what
you could do is hide the
player view until
initialization successes
come back and then load
the video into it.
But usually, it's just going to
be under 200 milliseconds
or so in modern devices, at
which point the player view
will be initialized.
And once you have one player
view initialized, then the
service is already
up and running.
It'll be much faster each
time to connect.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And as you said, the whole
process is asynchronous.
So the developer can actually
trigger the initialization at
the best opportunity for
a given application.
ROSS MCILROY: Exactly.
And the UI looks much the same
while it's loading the service
as when it's loading the
first video, buffering.
So there's a seamless
transition there.
The user shouldn't notice a
difference between the API
initializing and the first
video buffering.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Well, thank you very much
for your time, Ross.
I know you need to run off and
do your holiday shopping.
Is that correct?
ROSS MCILROY: Yeah.
I've been too busy building
the API to
do any holiday shopping.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
Well, hopefully you
will have enough
time before the holidays.
Thank you very much again.
And for those of you who
are watching, thank
you for your attention.
And we'll see you again on
YouTube Developers Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]